matt james's journey as the bachelor
who better to talk about all things
bachelor nation
than mr chris harrison himself it's time
for
roses and rosay this journey has
been such a whirlwind of emotions i
think it's evident of how
deep tasha's connections with these
remaining guys are
how is this all gonna end she has
unbelievably strong feelings she is
falling in love
but is that gonna be reciprocated fully
it's like is there a proposal gone wrong
i will just say this it is incredibly
emotional when you see her broken
hearted and you see her
at that level it is it's just different
it really does hit you in a different
way
hello you released matt james as women
uh give me a couple women to watch for
here queen victoria is here
and uh she's here to rule bree uh is
is a woman who left an unbelievably
high-paying tech
job there are 32 women a record number
of women applied for matt james
um that's how many arrive on night one
that's not how many we'll end up with
there will be more than those that
arrive and i can also give you this
nugget
one woman who arrives is a very very
familiar face to bad coronation
how would you kind of describe the vibe
of matt's season if colton was the
virgin and
pete was the pilot what's matt yeah
there is so much depth there is so
many layers to this man that you're
going to get to know
um good and bad okay so you're saying
there's more to matt than
all the abs we've seen with him and
tyler cameron on instagram
you see the six pack okay there's a 12
pack here
okay good to know we want more more is
[Music]
better